poutine
j'ai vu un panneau devant avec une
annonce vous cherchez une assistante
oui
[Musique]
avez-vous de l'expérience dans les arts
funéraire non mais j'apprends vite
chaque cadavre raconte une histoire
c'est à nous de les écouter
pour découvrir les indices
extraire la vérité donc tout ça raconte
comment les gens sont morts seulement
comment ma chère mais pourquoi
[Musique]
regardez de plus près le diable est dans
les détails
[Musique]
ah ah ah ah
j'avais pas vu venir celle là
[Musique]
pourquoi tu es allé là bas je t'avais
dit c'est dangereux
tu connais ces gens manifester
le vieil homme c'est son fils
il est là pour aider la femme elle
pratique les vieilles coutumes cdu une
bourre
qui ne savent pas s'ils peuvent te
laisser partir parce qu'ils se
retrouvaient quelque chose en toi
[Musique]
je sais pas ce qu'il ya dans ma mourinho
tu comprends vraiment rien
de ce qui se passe ici est ce que tu
vois
sur
cette enquête
christina tu sais que les démons ça
n'existe pas
je m'appelle christina lopez je suis
venu pour mourir ici
nos condoléances pour votre grand père
j'avais plus clean tech grand père ne
faisait jamais rien comme tout le monde
je suis fait une nouvelle copine c'est
une louve elle vient souvent me voir
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu fais
agent simpson et richardson qui s'est
passé quelque chose d'irréel
cet avion qui s'écrasait c'est terrible
l'avion transportait un lionceau destiné
à un cirque on doit le retrouver comme
tu vas jamais croire bien voir ya un
louveteau un lionceau et bouge sans que
ce que chez soi c'est une copine de
grand-père quoi
séparables
la louve est parvenu je vais devoir
m'occuper d'eux
vous n'avez aucun droit sur ces bêtes
rendez moi mon lyon je vous promets
qu'ils vous arrivera rien
comment tu t'en l'occupera quand ils
seront adultes italie protéger
ils s'adorent
je vais récupérer - lyon d'une manière
ou d'une autre
enfin nous ayons
à nous et aux
[Musique]
populations
pour la planète est menacée
sa nourriture des populations
elle était nécessaire et à l'algérie
les marteaux piqueurs
la
cnds
[Musique]
presque
jacquy mouginy
[Applaudissements]
une charte est un phénomène complexe
[Musique]
ah
bah
les pilotes esprits pour cet été
allez la série
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le plâtre
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
hugues and protect
end of town
le trafic cff
[Musique]
et
cette inconnue se peut-il que celui que
j'ai connu soit l'homme qui m'a fait
jouer trois fois
qui dit je suis battu d'ouvrir ce
mystérieux inconnu
que je connais déjà
c'est pat c'est mon fils il est de
retour un autre homme
fit quelques zones dissidente et baskets
je
grand amour secret est de retour
barbara
[Musique]
surtout ne soyez pas vous même
je suis moi
quand je suis toi
crowley
quand écolo
je suis sur ses pattes je suis moi
quand je suis toi
[Musique]
tu sois je te lâcherai pas en ferait pas
être merci dont les stars
[Musique]
moubarak ce temps
analyse dont
kadhafi
[Musique]
sourire
en charge border itunes
quand gobain
dan fegan moyenne 100 chaliand
nico batum
le courage c'est aussi à
sarret poursuites
6 am i wanna be trop
[Musique]
notre comptage et fontana et
l'armateur tard car 9,7
ballack alimentera d'athènes
[Musique]
et moi je teste pas
m